So, Trump is in China.
This happened about um 30 minutes ago.
An hour south of us. So, Trump came in
last night, and this morning he met with
President Xi at the Great Hall of the
People. And let's just have a quick
look.
This is him getting out of his
limousine. This was bought in from the
United States by a military transport.
He brought uh his entire cabinet,
including uh Marco Rubio, the Secretary
of State,
as well as Peter Hegseth, who is the
uh Secretary of War.
Okay.
The last time an American president
visited was 9 years ago, November 2017.
So, this is a very historical meeting.
And as you may remember,
after Trump visited Beijing,
um
they started the trade war. And we've
been in a trade war ever since.
I think that this meeting
is very optimistic for US-China
relations. A lot has to do with who came
with Trump. So, um this is from Weibo,
the Chinese Twitter.
And what Chinese are focusing on is who
came with Trump. So, many of his family
members came with Trump, including his
son Eric,
uh his daughter-in-law Lara.
Um and they were excited about coming to
China. Team China, guys, okay? Much more
important is the number of business
executives who came with Trump. So, you
have Elon Musk of Tesla, and of course
he does a lot of business in China. Tim
Cook of Apple also does a lot of
business in China. Boeing
is trying to secure a $50 billion um
sale to Chinese Airlines.
And so, these are our three um very
important business people. And then you
have some of the leading financial
people in America, including Larry Fink
of BlackRock, uh Stephen Schwarzman of
Blackstone,
uh David Solomon of Goldman Sachs, you
have Citigroup, you have MasterCard, and
Visa. Okay? And these are the leading
financial companies
in America.
And all together, these business
executives, if you put all their net the
companies' net worth together,
their companies are worth over $12
trillion. That's a lot of money.
And these are very busy people.
And quite honestly, I've worked in
business negotiations.
You do not bring
these people together one room unless
you have a mega deal to announce to the
world.
Okay? So, my prediction is that
um by tomorrow we should have the broad
contours of a US-China grand bargain,
where the two nations reconcile their
differences, and they start a new
chapter
uh in world history where they work
together to stabilize the global
economy.
So, what I want to do today is discuss
how we got here,
why a grand bargain will happen, and
what this grand bargain will look like.
Okay?
All right.
So, let's discuss some of the events
that led to this uh meeting between C
and Trump. This is David Lee from
Twitter, okay? And he's And he's talking
about like the past month
what happened. So, the first thing that
happened is that China blocked Manas.
Manas is an AI company
uh that Mark Zuckerberg tried to buy.
And Manas was uh incubated in China.
And if you're an AI company,
you get become very successful, you want
to go to United States because that's
where all the money is, that's where all
the talent is, that's how you become
really, really big.
But because it was it was um incubated
in China, China said it no, you can't go
to United States because this would set
a bad precedent. China is trying to grow
its own talent. So, this shows um the AI
war being fought between China and the
United States, okay? So, that's one
thing that happened. Another thing that
happened is that the US imposed
sanctions on Chinese companies that do
business
with Iran, including satellite companies
that sell commercial intelligence
to Iran on where US bases are, um teapot
refineries, which take
uh Iranian oil and then convert it into
energy that China can use.
Okay?
And in response, China said, "No, you
cannot impose sanctions on us. If you
impose sanctions on us, and if people
comply with these sanctions, then we,
the Chinese government, will sanction
these people as well." Okay, this this
this is something called the blocking
order.
And
this also seems like an escalation in
the US-China trade war, where previously
Chinese institutions, banks, individuals
complied with US sanctions. This is the
first time the Chinese government said
to Chinese people, "If you're a Chinese
citizen and you comply with US
sanctions, then we will sanction you."
Okay? So, this is a very big deal.
Um Nvidia
was not able to sell chips into
China. And this is going to affect
Nvidia's bottom line. Okay? Nvidia is
right now the world's the world's most
valuable company, primarily because AI
depends on their chips.
Okay?
Um China invited Iranian Foreign
Minister Araghchi to Beijing because
China is very interested in the outcome
of this war between the United States
and Iran.
Uh right now,
um Iran is blocking the Strait of
Hormuz, and China depends on 50 to 60%
of its energy needs from the Middle
East. Okay?
Um
Jensen Huang was not on the China list.
Okay? So, before Trump took off, it was
announced that
Jensen Huang, who is the head of Nvidia,
would not come to China.
And this is a very big deal because in
this grand bargain, what China would
want is access to Nvidia's
uh chips, semiconductors, in order to
fuel its AI. Okay?
Um the United States and six other
nations had a war game in the
Philippines, and then China sent 28
warships. Okay?
Uh Trump sent Iran an MOU.
Uh Iran made modifications, and Trump
said, "No." Okay? So, it seems like the
war will only increase
in the Middle East.
After Iran had responded, China
announced Trump's state of visit.
Um and then
uh
yesterday and the day before,
He Lifeng, who is the uh who is a vice
premier in China, and Scott Bessent, who
is the Treasury Secretary, met in South
Korea to try to negotiate um
a a deal, okay? And then what's going to
happen is that Putin will visit China
after Trump leaves.
So, if you just look at what's
happening, it seems as though there's
still a lot of friction between the
United States and China. What I want to
show you today is that all of this you
can just ignore, okay? This is all
that's happening
right now. But if we use game theory, if
we just look at the broad contours of
what's happening,
we would make much better predictions
as to what will happen, okay? So, all
this I think is just theater.
All right?
The China and the United States are not
actually fighting AI war. It's all
theater. They're actually working
together to promote AI.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
these sanctions are happening, but
eventually
the US and China will come to a grand
bargain, and they will become much more
economically integrated.
And Iran China doesn't really care about
Iran,
okay? China cares first and foremost
about
um the relationship with the United
States. And one piece of evidence for
that is that when Foreign Minister Zarif
went to Moscow, Putin met with him for
40 for 90 minutes, and Putin expressed
his sympathy and support to the Iranian
people.
When
Zarif came to Beijing, he only met with
his counterpart, the uh Foreign Minister
Wang Yi.
Okay?
All right.
Uh another important thing is that Scott
Bessent
is the one who is leading the US team in
China. Scott Bessent is the Treasury
Secretary.
This goes against protocol because uh uh
it's usually
the Secretary of State, Marco Rubio,
and the National Security Advisor, who
all who also happens to be Marco Rubio,
this team is the one that sets the
agenda for the US-China visit.
Because it's Scott Bessent, we can
probably guess that this is probably
going to be an economic negotiation, and
the focus is on will be on finance.
Basically, what America wants is for
China to open up its financial sector
for companies like BlackRock and
Blackstone to come in to sell financial
instruments
to Chinese people, okay? That That's
what America wants. And we'll talk about
more about this as as we go along.
All right, let's continue.
Okay. So, in the geopolitical landscape,
um it seems as though
America is trying to contain China. So,
uh this is
Tehran.
And this is what China's trying to do.
China's trying to build a high-speed
rail network from Beijing all the way
across Central Asia and into Europe,
okay? This is the land route that
Beijing wants to take in order to
maintain trade with Europe. As you can
tell from this map, Tehran is the pivot
or the hub of this trade network, okay?
Without Tehran,
Beijing could not access Europe.
Um it And then Moscow also sees Tehran
as very important as well for its
north-south trade access.
Without Tehran, Beijing is completely
reliant on Russia. Beijing does not want
to become reliant on Russia.
Beijing sees itself as the third axis of
power in the world.
All right, you have the United States,
you have Russia, and then you have
China.
From a geopolitical perspective,
China doesn't want to become partners
with either the United States or or or
Russia. It It It wants to become
independent. It wants to create its own
sphere of influence. Okay, and that's
why Iran is very very important. So, a
lot of geopolitical
geopolitical analysts believe that
Beijing is forced to
support Iran in this war. And what I
want to show you is that's not actually
the case.
All right? China's China's may want to
become independent of the United States
and Russia, but it cannot actually.
All right. Um
Now, there's a rumor
a couple of days ago that
one deal that Trump and Xi will will
sign in Beijing is
Xi Jinping will commit
$1 trillion dollars
$1 trillion
investment into America, primarily
factories that manufacture EV cars. This
is a huge deal.
Okay?
And Laura Laura
Ingraham, who works at Fox News, she
thinks it's a bad thing. She thinks that
this is about uh China coming in and
trying to buy out the uh United States.
As I'll show you later, this is
Okay? I think this deal will
happen, but this is a deal
that shows that China is is ultimately
dependent on America as opposed to China
wants to take over America.
Okay?
All right.
So,
um how can we understand the Trump
visit? Well, again, in this class, what
I want to show you is that
historical analogies is a really
powerful way to understand the present.
So, the Trump visit today is analogous
to Nixon's visit in 1972.
Okay?
So, you you you don't know this, but
before 1972,
America was hostile towards
China,
primarily because of Taiwan,
where during the Chinese Civil War, the
Americans were were supportive of uh
Chiang Kai-shek and the KMT. They lost,
they went to Taiwan.
And when that happened, America said
that, first of all, we will only
recognize Taiwan as the official
government of China. Second of all, we
will refuse to do any business
with the PRC.
And third of all, we will help Taiwan
eventually try to take over uh
uh China. 1972, when Nixon visited, this
marked a radical departure
from 20 years
of
um American foreign policy.
Okay? And the question then is, why
would he do that? And the answer is, in
1971,
the Nixon shock.
So, if you talk to historians, they'll
give you lots and lots of different
reasons as to why Nixon visited
China. The main reason, in their from
their perspective, is that um Henry
Kissinger, who was National Security
Advisor to uh Richard Nixon, he was
trying to triangulate
uh between China and the Soviet Union,
right? He was trying to get China on the
side of the United States in order to
um defeat the Soviet Union. That's not
true. That's something that historians
made up. The real reason is that in
1971,
Nixon removed
the US dollar from the gold standard.
And now the US dollar is worth nothing.
Before you could take the US dollar and
change it for gold, now it's worth
nothing.
If it's worth nothing, what you do now
is create a demand for it. You basically
have to create a Ponzi scheme.
And so, Nixon did two things to resolve
this issue and create the US dollar
Ponzi scheme. The first thing he did was
create something called the petrodollar.
Okay?
The petrodollar is where Saudi Arabia
and other Middle East countries, like
Qatar,
UAE, they only sell their oil in US
dollars.
So now, before the value of US dollars
was pegged was tied to gold the gold
standard, now the value of US dollars is
tied to oil.
Okay? If you want to buy oil, and
everyone wants to buy oil, you need US
dollars. And that's something called the
petrodollar.
Okay, that's the first thing. Second
thing, which is relevant to us, is
China, okay? Opening.
The strategy is to turn China into a
manufacturing base for the global
economy.
Right? So, the
Middle East sells oil to the world.
But China now will sell manufactured
goods to the world, and China will also
do so
using US dollars.
And these two things together create
um the current global economy.
All right?
Okay. So,
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
explain to you
why America did this, okay?
This is what we call the Shanghai
Communique.
This is published 1972.
And this basically spells out the basic
premise, framework for all future
US-China cooperation and dialogue.
And the Shanghai framework basically
resolves the Taiwan question.
And with regard to Taiwan question,
America practices
should strategic ambiguity.
Meaning,
the United States will not be clear
about the issue of Taiwan with regard to
China.
So, what the United States has been
saying for a long time is
we do not support Taiwan independence.
Okay, that's a strategic ambiguity.
China would prefer the United States to
say, "We oppose
Taiwan independence." In which case, the
United States is obligated now to
prevent Taiwan from becoming
independent.
Okay, that's what China would prefer,
but the United States practices
strategic ambiguity saying, "We do not
support."
I would not be surprised if over the
next few months
Trump rapidly changes
his attitude and declares
that the United States is opposed to
Taiwan independence. In fact, the United
States supports the unification
of China and Taiwan.
Okay? This will be a radical sea shift
from previous administrations.
And I'll explain why later on why Trump
would do this. And also why it's
actually very strategic and smart for
the United States to want to support
Taiwan and China reunification. Okay?
All right.
So,
um let me explain now
what the China-US relationship really is
using the theories that we've learned in
this class.
Okay? There's something that you will
never learn that that you will not not
learn anywhere else.
And this is speculation on my part.
Please take it with a grain of salt.
Please question me. Please debate me,
okay? But this is my theory of how the
US and China work together.
And once you understand this theory, you
can then go on to make certain
predictions about how the United States
and China will behave moving forward.
And based on whether these predictions
are correct or not, you can then figure
out if this theory is correct or not,
okay? All right. So,
the first thing to understand, and
something that I've been teaching a lot
in this class, is that reality
is a hallucination.
It is something that we collectively
imagine together. And again, the
analogy, the metaphor I use is Plato's
allegory of the cave, where you imagine
about a million people
chained together,
and they're all looking at a wall, okay?
This wall is empty. Behind the wall,
behind the people, is this great fire,
where the elite, okay? We don't know who
they are, okay? But they project shadows
onto the wall.
And then the people who are chained
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes. They only see what's in front of
them, which is the wall. They see the
shadows, and they start to create
a reality around the shadows. They think
these shadows are real,
and they think
um and they create mythology, religion,
an entire framework around the shadows.
Okay? And this is what we call reality.
All right. So, the main message here is
that
true wealth
is our attention.
The Okay?
Our consciousness is what's true wealth.
In fact, our consciousness is what's
real. Everything else is an illusion.
Everything else is is a shadow. Your
body is a shadow.
Okay? The person in front of you is a
shadow.
This blackboard is a shadow. What's real
is the thing inside your head. The Your
consciousness is what's real. Now, what
power is
is the capacity to direct and control
this attention.
Okay? How I exert power over you is by
making you think the way I want you to
think. By making you see what I want you
to see. Okay? So, if I can make you see
these shadows and make you think it's
real, then that's what true power is.
And this is this idea, once you
understand it, explains the reality that
we live in. Okay? So, I'm going to take
this idea and apply it to reality and
show you how it works.
So,
at the very basis of reality is the
empire. Okay? It is the American empire
that's able to force you to sit down and
look at the wall.
Then the people manipulating the fire,
casting the shadows, are the game
masters. And these are the financial
elite, okay? Including the Bank of
International Settlements,
uh the Federal Reserve,
uh
Wall Street,
City of London,
basically private capital.
They together
create the conditions for this game.
They're able to direct
our attention, okay? And the the
mechanism they do this with is of course
with capital, okay? Or US dollars.
And then from And then again they create
something called the global economy, of
course, right? The global economy.
But in order for this game to work,
it has to the game masters have to
disguise the fact that they're really in
charge. So they create institutions
that pretend to be objective,
international, and impartial, and fair,
but are but are in fact controlled by
the game masters. It These are include
of include of course the UN, the WTO,
uh the EU,
um the World Bank, okay? Lots and lots
of these organizations.
And then in order to justify and
legitimize this system, in order to make
you think these shadows are real,
um
they
media,
education,
and culture
brainwash you, indoctrinate you into
believing this system is real, when it
it's all just a a a hallucination, okay?
And then from this of course you have
uh the legal system to enforce the
system, as well as customs and habits,
values, and norms.
Okay? So this is an enforcement
mechanism to force you to believe that
this system system is real.
Okay? Uh Uh media, education, culture
brainwashes you to believe this system
is real, and then you yourself want to
enforce the system on others
through
customs and
norms. Okay? Now,
this is a very
fragile system because it's all just a
uh hallucination.
So, there are enforcement mechanisms
Okay? That make sure this system is
stable. And these enforcement mechanisms
are crime,
intelligence, spies basically, spy
networks,
um and science.
Okay? And they these three mechanisms
are controlled by the true powers of
this world.
And they include transnational capital,
basically private capital,
secret societies,
and elite families.
And what binds them together, their
basically software, their operating
system is what
Okay? And we'll say more about the
occult later on.
All right. Okay, so this is how the
world is designed.
Again, this is all a
hallucination.
One thing that you don't appreciate of
this system is that from this
hallucination, I can actually project
myself onto another force and create
another hallucination. Okay? That's what
Richard Nixon did.
From this system, in order to maintain
the empire, in order to maintain the
supremacy of the US dollar,
Okay? He created two new hallucinations.
And they are the GCC and China.
Okay?
GCC
and China.
All right. So, what underpinned this
system before was gold. The fact that US
dollar could always be exchanged for
gold. Once that's gone, then you need to
create new two new hallucinations in
order to disguise
the the hallucination, okay?
So, what happened was that
over next few decades
this system will transport itself and
impose itself on the GCC and China.
Okay? This system here.
It will impose itself into
the GCC as well as China.
In other words, and this is really
important for you guys to understand,
China is a hallucination
of a hallucination. It's not real.
Okay, I'll explain more about this later
on, okay?
All right.
So,
once this hallucination is imposed onto
the GCC and China, this creates demand
for the US dollar. Okay? And this
creates certain stability
for the US dollar. And it made China
very, very wealthy.
Okay?
But,
it's all just an illusion. It's all just
a mirage. There's some problems with
this system. First of all,
China doesn't have any creativity. Okay?
Why? Because if you're a hallucination
of a hallucination, there's nothing for
you to base yourself on.
Okay? You're a shadow of a shadow.
That's the first problem. Second problem
is
um wealth
extraction. Okay? The idea here is that
whatever wealth China creates has to be
turned to the source.
Because the people inside China
appreciate that
the women be
its entire value is based on the US
dollar. So, you have women be or US
dollar?
Of course, you want US dollar.
Okay?
And the third problem
is
the fragility of the system.
Okay? Meaning that
if this system the hallucination is
unstable
then China is even more unstable because
it's a hallucination of a hallucination.
Okay, do you understand?
Okay. So, once we understand this
then we begin to we reassess what
happened these past 10 years. Why do the
United States and China fight this trade
war?
The reason why is that China believed
that it could be independent
of this hallucination. In fact, it could
create its own hallucination.
And the US says, "No, no, no, guys. No,
no, no. You're going to be dependent on
us." So, then they started to fight this
trade war. Once this trade war happened,
what happened? A lot of money and people
started to flee China
and move back to the United States.
Okay?
And now what China has recognized is,
"Okay, first of all
we can't actually leave this
hallucination
because if this hallucination were to
collapse, we collapse as well.
So, what we can do actually is actually
to
recouple, okay?
To bind ourselves even greater to the
system. Now, the reason I'm saying this
is that the US the global economy is
under a lot of strain. There are two
main beneficiaries of the global
economy, the United States and China.
So, both are heavily invested in
maintaining the illusion, the
hallucination that is the global
economy.
Okay? And to appreciate how fragile all
this is, think of the UAE. Okay? The
UAE.
The UAE seen as though it was a very
prosperous place.
Right? It had universities from America
like Georgetown,
Cornell.
It had people the wealthiest people
flocking to Dubai.
It's seen invisible.
But the moment you attack the UAE like
if you had just flopped a missile at
UAE, that the illusion shatters. And now
the UAE is gone. You understand?
That's how precarious these illusions
are.
One hit at the right spot, the entire
illusion is shattered. You can never
bring it back.
Okay?
And so that's what China's afraid of
now. So that's why
China and the United States have to work
together because what's important is to
maintain the nature of reality itself.
The worst thing that can happen is if
people wake up from this dream. Because
if you wake up from this dream,
everything collapses all at once.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys? Any
questions so far?
Are we clear about this? Okay. All
right. So how how Now that we have this
theory, let's talk about this idea
concretely. Okay?
All right.
So
the United States used to be the world's
most powerful manufacturing country,
okay? So before it was it was the UK,
then you have the United States, okay?
And the United States is in the blue.
Right?
And then it
And then China surpassed it. This is
intentional.
Okay? The intention is to use
manufacturing to extract the wealth of
China and transfer it to
America.
Okay, so now China is the world's most
powerful manufacturing country, okay?
And this this is a map that shows it
better.
Okay, where China is now number one,
United States has moved on to number
two, Japan and Germany are pretty flat.
This is intentional. The The intention
is to bind China to the global economy,
to become dependent on the global
economy, and therefore save the global
economy when it's under strain.
Okay, one major consequence
of
this
um
uh all of all of China's rise is
the trade deficit
between
America and China.
Okay?
Unfortunately, this trade deficit is a
natural consequence
of
um China's manufacturing
uh ascent.
Okay? Why? Because the purpose is to
force China to buy more US dollars.
Okay?
In order to support the Ponzi scheme.
So, this is a system that benefits the
Americans. When Trump came into power in
2016, he said, "No, no, no, no. It shows
that China is taking advantage of us."
And Trump doesn't really really
appreciate that. No, it was designed
this way. You You need to create demand
for US dollars. If China is buying a lot
of US dollars, that's a good thing,
right? China is trading real assets, the
energy of its people, for fake assets,
which is just
mm US dollars, okay? So, it's a good
deal for America, but Trump said, "No,
this is a bad deal." And this And this
was what led to the trade war.
Okay.
So, what led to the trade war is the
WTO.
So, in 1999,
China negotiated to join the WTO, the
World Trade Organization.
And this is this is what going to make
China rich and the largest manufacturing
power in the world. But in order to join
WTO, China had to
uh agree to a lot of conditions. The two
most important conditions was
protect IP, okay?
You have to protect
other nations intellectual property and
you have to enforce it. The other thing
was
open the financial sector.
The goal is USD
renminbi convertibility.
Okay?
So, these are the two things America
wanted from China. First of all, to
ensure that all US IP will be protected
in China rigorously. Second thing is to
allow any Chinese to convert their money
into US dollars.
As you can appreciate,
these two demands are actually bad for
China.
Okay? So, China was not very stringent
about protecting IP. This is what led to
the rise of Huawei.
Basically, Huawei can take Apple IP
and make these great computers. So, in
the year 2016,
when Trump first came into power,
Huawei computers were actually better
than Apple computers because Huawei was
constantly innovating and they were
trying to make their computers as cheap
as possible, whereas Apple was
essentially a monopoly. Okay?
And this led to United States imposing
trade sanctions on Huawei because it was
too competitive against Apple.
The second problem is
even worse because you think about it,
if you just open up your financial
sector,
all the money in China runs off to
United States because Chinese appreciate
that we are a hallucination of a
hallucination of a hallucination. Your
dollars is more valuable than your means
based on your dollars. So, wouldn't it
make more sense to just convert all your
yuan bi into US dollars?
But then all of this would of course
cause the collapse of the Chinese
economy.
Right? So, the the Chinese government
would refuse to open the financial
sector, and that's what started the
trade war
in 2016. Oh, sorry, not 2016, in 2018,
okay? 2018 is when the war actually
started, up to today.
So, for the past 8 years, this war's
been going on because America's trying
to protect its IP, and and because
America wasn't going to open up its
financial sector.
The reason why
Trump has come to China,
the reason why he's brought so many
executives is because China has
essentially agreed to open up its
financial sector, okay? I'll I'll
discuss this later on.
But you got you got you got to
appreciate how this war started and why
and why it's going to end.
All right. Now, the thing about this war
is that for the past 8 years,
China and the United States have been
attacking each other. There are two
There are two main mechanisms in which
China attacked the United States. The
first mechanism is by restricting
the supply of rare earth minerals to the
United States. Because as as you can see
from this chart,
China actually produces most of the rare
earth minerals. Now, you may not know
this, but actually rare earths aren't
that rare. The problem is in the
extraction. It is very expensive. It is
very environmentally costly. China is
willing to pay pay these costs. The rest
of the world isn't. That's why China has
essentially a monopoly over lithium,
cobalt, graphite, and other rare earths
that the EV industry, the solar
industry, the semiconductor industry are
highly dependent on. Okay?
That's the first attack vector. Second
attack vector is the China appreciates
that
China's value to the global economy is
that it purchases a lot of US dollars.
So then China started to buy more gold,
okay? So you can see how uh the US
treasuries went down, but then gold went
way up.
Okay?
And so this is the way that China is
trying to exert pressure on the United
States. The problem is that China is
much more vulnerable to attack than than
the United States.
Okay? The United States is a is a
hallucination, but China is a
hallucination of a of a hallucination.
The first thing to appreciate is that
China's
energy dependence is huge. China
wastes Sorry, China uses twice as much
energy as America for its manufacturing
sector in order to create exports.
Therefore, China is vulnerable to
embargoes and sanctions, okay? And so
what America is doing right now with
this war in the middle in the Middle
East by
um kidnapping Maduro in Venezuela, it's
basically choking China off from its
energy energy supply.
Okay? That's one problem with Second
problem is that China is very export
oriented. Okay? So the entire economy is
just basically on exporting manufactured
goods cheaply to the rest of the world.
And you can you can tell because most of
the world's biggest ports are actually
based in China, okay? The business is
Shanghai,
uh followed by um Singapore, Ningbo,
Shenzhen, Qingdao, Guangzhou. Okay? So
four
Sorry, five of the world's top six
export hubs are based in China. That
shows you China's dependence on
exports. But, if China If America's
controlling the seas and controlling
through its choke points like the Strait
of Malacca and um the Strait of Hormuz
and Strait of Gibraltar, Panama Canal,
that shows a huge problem for China.
Okay?
And the third thing
is how much resources China uses. China
in only 3 years time, okay? From 2011 to
2013, used more cement
than America did in 100 years.
That's crazy to think about.
All right?
So, this shows you how dependent China
is on the global economy. It It also
shows you how dependent China is on the
USD. Okay? Because it's only because the
renminbi can be exchanged for the USD
that allows China to purchase so many
resources from
um abroad.
All right.
The reality is that China is too
dependent on America. This is something
that Chinese policy makers have been
have have been trying to change for the
past 10 years. It doesn't work. Because
what Chinese policy policy makers don't
understand is that you're in a
hallucination of a hallucination.
Okay? You only exist because America
created you. All right. So, this is
consumer confidence.
You can see
um so, 2018
is when the trade war started, okay?
And at this time
uh people are still okay. They're still
bearing the brunt of it. But, then COVID
happened, right? And then you saw this
massive drop. And it never really
recovered, guys.
All right? It never really recovered.
Consumer confidence.
People don't believe the economy is
doing well. People are not willing to
buy things.
People aren't working. People are losing
income.
Right?
The economy is not doing well. At the
same time, this is really interesting,
more and more Chinese students are
choosing to study abroad even as the
economy is failing. Even as though there
are less and less less opportunities to
do well in China, more and more Chinese
are going to America to study. And guess
what?
Not the very best are not coming back,
okay? There's a gap of about a million
students
who
stay in the West. And these are often
the very best students.
All right? So,
I hate to say this, but you're
hallucinating with
hallucination, you're anxious. You want
to go back to the source.
Right? So, you know there will be space
on your dollars. You can change your RMB
for your dollars, you will do so.
If you can flee the country,
immigrate abroad, you will do so.
All right.
This is a pretty stark
data, okay?
So, um
this shows you the current account
balance. Current account
Current account is basically means how
much Chinese Chinese have in the bank
due to trade.
This
um is
the trade account, okay? How much
Chinese actually traded.
The The blue tracks the current account,
okay? How much
Chinese have in the bank because of the
trade.
The
red
tracks the actual trade.
Okay? As you can see, for most of
Chinese history up until about, you
know,
uh 2022,
it tracks pretty closely.
But, starting in 2022,
there's a divergence. A huge divergence.
You know what? That's 5 billion dollars
a year, guys.
Why is this happening?
Capital flight, money laundering.
People are using exports in order to
move their money out of the country.
It's very It's a very simple thing
where, okay, maybe
um
uh I buy a refrigerator from you, right?
It should be five five hundred dollars.
We agree for five five hundred dollars,
but you charge me a thousand dollars.
Why? Because you didn't take the five
five hundred dollars, and you put that
money on my behalf into a US real
estate. You buy property or buy stocks
from me, okay? Does that make sense?
This is all just money laundering.
Okay? So, in other words, what's really
driving China's export mania,
a lot of it is just money laundering.
As people try to flee the country.
Okay? So, this is not good for China.
All right.
Um another major problem
in China
is the household savings rate.
Where it's the highest in the world.
Okay?
The highest in the world. Why is Chi-
Why are Chinese
um savers Why are they saving 40% of
their income? Well, a lot of reason is
because Chinese aren't that wealthy,
okay? So, even though the Chinese
economy has boomed these past 30 40
years, the Chinese individual has not
seen a huge improvement
in his
um standard of living, okay?
And so, there is
not a great confidence in the future,
and that's why Chinese save a lot of
their money.
And there are not that many actual that
that many investment vehicles as well.
So, from a US perspective, this is a
great opportunity, right?
If Chinese are saving all this money,
if you're a financier, if you're like
BlackRock or a BlackRock, you're like,
"Why don't you give it to me? And I'll
invest the money for you and give you
bigger returns."
Right? This is why they're here in
China, cuz they want this. They want all
that capital stored in in Chinese banks
not doing anything. Like, "Give it to us
and we'll make you more money, okay?"
All right.
Um,
so,
this shows you
the capital account. All All this is
saying is that you can't actually
convert your yuan renminbi into other
currencies.
So, most countries
have
full
uh, open capital accounts, okay?
The The black um, is most countries.
The
bottom quarter of nations have closed
accounts, and China is part of the
uh, quarter that have closed accounts,
okay? So, Chinese can actually take take
their money and leave the country.
Okay. So,
the other thing that I want you guys to
understand is, from a US perspective,
there's still a lot of potential in
China. And the reason why is China still
has a lot of debt capacity.
Debt capacity just means
your ability to carry debt.
Why? Because China doesn't have much
debt relative to other nations. Look at
this, okay?
China,
in terms of like assets and liabilities,
don't have much invested abroad. You can
compare that with like other countries
like Japan, United States, Germany,
United Kingdom, they have a lot invested
abroad.
China doesn't have that much invested
abroad. So, in theory, you can encourage
the Chinese to buy more things abroad,
which would which would
help the global economy, right? In
theory.
Now, what's interesting is that China
doesn't invest uh much abroad relative
to other rich nations, but China doesn't
invest much abroad relative to all
nations, okay? So, this is China. It's
about the same as India, which doesn't
have that much capital, then like even
Indonesia, Turkey, Mexico actually
invests more abroad than China does.
Brazil,
Russia, Saudi Arabia invests a lot,
South Africa invests a lot more than
China. Okay? So, again, from a US
financial financial perspective, China
is a large great opportunity
in the world. That's why they're coming
here.
Okay? They want to strike a deal where
they can financialize the China the
Chinese economy. Basically, use uh the
Chinese economy as collateral to engage
in financial speculation everywhere in
the world. Okay? So, let me explain how
they're going to do so. All right.
So, China has
a closed
capital account.
>> [music]
>> Why do you have a closed capital
account? Because you know for a fact
that if you open it, Chinese take the
yuan B and convert all into US dollars.
All right? And that causes your economy
to collapse, your bank system to
collapse. So,
So, what's the solution here? Okay,
first of all, what we need to understand
something and this is like really
important for you guys to appreciate.
Banks
create money out of thin air.
Okay?
Money is just an illusion.
So, the example is, let's just say
you're a depositor
and you put a million dollars
into a bank. Right? And the the way the
bank makes makes money is by lending it
to entrepreneurs, right? So, you then as
a bank, you give a million dollars a
loan to a to a restaurant entrepreneur.
Okay?
And this is how banks work.
And you think that, okay, well, if
deposit a million dollars in the bank,
the bank then loans it to the to the
restaurant entrepreneur,
then in theory, the bank should have
zero
in the bank, right? No. The bank now has
two million dollars.
Okay?
The banks are allowed, according to
accounting,
they're allowed to create money every
time they issue a loan.
So,
that only they keep that million dollars
from the depositor, but they also are
able to print a million dollars to give
to the restaurant entrepreneur. Does
that make sense to you guys?
Okay. Do you guys want to want to know
why this is the case?
Okay, I'll tell you anyway, okay?
All right. Okay.
So, before,
what were what were banks? Banks were
just merchants, okay? A merchant
alliance.
Why? Because merchants needed capital in
order to trade. So, they came together
and created their own bank. Okay, so
they were an alliance. And so, what
merchants would do is basically deposit
their gold
into this alliance so that it can be
distributed elsewhere.
Okay?
Now, the problem gold is that it's
heavy, it's hard to transport. It's also
dangerous because there are pirates,
okay? So, the way that they use the way
that they use gold in order to create an
um
exchanges in order to create business is
to use receipts. Receipts
are contracts.
So, rather than me give you the gold
physically, I just give you a piece of
paper saying that I guarantee that this
paper can be redeemed for gold at my
bank. Okay, does that make sense?
All right.
And then you have to keep track of these
exchanges.
So, they created something called
double-entry bookkeeping, which is
basically assets and liabilities.
Okay? And that's double-entry book
bookkeeping. Something that we still use
today.
So, let's just say I have a million
dollars in gold.
Okay? Well, that's easy. I just put it
into assets, right?
Okay? Then someone comes and says, "I
need I need to borrow a million dollars
of gold." I'm like, "Fine, I'll give you
a receipt for it."
Now, the problem My problem is, do I put
the receipt in liabilities or assets?
Assets, of course, right?
And that's how this system works.
And this is a system a system we still
use today.
That's why banks are allowed to create
money out of thin air
because of double-entry bookkeeping.
Okay, are you are you guys clear clear
about this?
Yeah?
Is it because that the
banks have powers to print money when
they
uh make loans or
Because I think like if
some people deposit their money into the
bank and the bank need to give it back.
So, it might be like into the liability.
Okay. All right. All right. All right.
All right. You don't You don't
understand what's going on. Okay. All
right. Listen. It's It's not that hard.
Okay? I have gold.
I put the gold into the bank. People
come to borrow the gold, right? And I
give a paper saying this is gold. This
It's It's money, okay? Money.
Okay? Is this money a debt or a
liability?
It doesn't make sense as a
It doesn't make sense as a liability
because I don't owe that thing.
Okay? And the fact that I can use this
this money in order to create more money
creates means it's an asset.
Okay? Does that make sense? All right.
So, so now this becomes a basis of the
global banking system. All right. So,
let let let me show you how. All right.
So, what happens is this. YOU HAVE THESE
BANKS
IN AMERICA, in the world. They're
private banks. They're run by private
people who put all their money in the
banks, okay?
You have the US government.
You have the government.
Okay.
The US government does not have any
money. The US government wants to borrow
money.
The question then is like, how do you
borrow money?
If you borrow money from these banks
individually, that's too hard, okay? So,
what happens is this.
What happens is 1913
the banks got together
and created something called the Federal
Reserve.
All right? Federal Federal Reserve
though it's at the heart it's just a
cartel of private banks in America.
Okay, do you understand?
Now the US government can just work with
the Federal Reserve and borrow money
directly from the Federal Reserve, which
represents all the banks in America.
Okay? So how does the US government sell
like borrow money from from the Federal
Reserve? It issues bonds. That's called
US Treasuries.
Okay? So the Federal Reserve can print
money to buy US Treasuries.
And then this money goes to the US
government.
And the US government can then
pay for expenses. Okay, does that make
sense?
All right. Now this system is fine. The
problem is that the US government spends
a lot of money. It fights wars, it wants
to send men to the moon, it wants to do
all to have a good life. Okay? So today
America has $39 trillion in debt.
And you're like, well who cares? Well,
the problem is this. The problem is the
interest rate, which is about 5%.
Okay? To Because in order to get the
Federal Reserve these private banks to
lend you the money, you have to give
them an interest rate. Otherwise, why
would they give Why would they lend you
the money, right?
Okay. So in other words,
5% means that the US government has to
pay the Federal Reserve about $2
trillion a year.
a year.
Where's it going to get $2 trillion a
year? It has to borrow more money from
the Federal Reserve.
All right? So this system is really
really unstable.
So now your problem is like, how do I
solve this problem?
You solve this problem by getting more
people to buy US Treasuries.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right, so you can get
governments
to buy US Treasuries, including the
Chinese government, the Japanese
government, the the UK government, okay?
And that's what And that's what what
what's been happening.
The problem is they only have a certain
amount of money they can borrow.
So, how do you get rid of this problem?
You get You get rid of this problem by
getting more people to buy
um
US Treasuries. And who are these people?
Everyone in the world. You, me, everyone
in the world.
Okay? This is what we call retail.
So, previously, it was only institutions
that want to buy US Treasuries.
And what they got What What the strategy
now is to get everyone to buy
US Treasuries. How?
You create a new financial mechanism
called stablecoins.
Okay? Stablecoins.
And And the two most popular stablecoins
are something called Tether
and Circle, okay? And the ideas are
simple. The idea is stablecoins are
backed by US Treasuries.
Meaning,
Tether and Circle have to buy US
Treasuries in order to sell stablecoins.
And then they can sell stablecoins to
anyone and everyone.
Okay? Including in China,
which has 40%
savings rate.
How?
Through institutions like um Apple,
BlackRock,
Visa.
Okay, does this make sense?
Now, you get around the problem of the
closed capital account.
Close up
Close capital account means you cannot
use yuan B to buy US dollars. With
stable coins, you can use Now you can
use yuan B to buy
Tether or Circle. Do you understand?
Okay? So, now what the US government is
going to do is they're going to transfer
that debt
onto the Chinese people.
Okay?
Okay. And so, you're like, "Okay, wait.
Wait a minute here.
$39 trillion is a lot of money, man.
Chinese people don't have $39 trillion."
Ch- America will never ever get rid of
rid of this debt, okay? But there's a
mechanism American can use to control
this debt. This debt And this is called
financial repression.
How does this work? Very simple.
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> So, um US Treasuries
are at 5%, right?
Really simple. I'll make this 0%, guys.
And you're like, "Wait a minute here. Uh
no, no, no, no. I don't understand this.
If it is 0%, I'm not going to buy US
Treasuries."
The answer, the solution is, I'll make
you buy it, guys. Okay? I force you to
buy it.
How do I force you to buy it? By passing
laws called the Genius Act
and the Clarity Act,
which compels stable coins
to use US Treasuries as a basis of their
digital currency.
And again, remember, if you're Chinese,
if you can keep your RMB at 5% a year or
US dollar at 0% a year, what do you
choose? You choose the US dollar at 0% a
year. Does that make sense, guys?
Okay? So, that's the solution, financial
repression. Why I drop the interest rate
of US Treasuries to nothing, which case
inflation
will destroy the debt over 50 years.
And I force people to buy it
by passing laws that force companies to
back the digital currency
with US Treasuries.
Forcing them to buy US Treasuries.
Does that make sense, guys?
Okay? And why And why do they do want to
do this? Because now they can access the
Chinese consumer. They can sell digital
currency to Chinese consumers. That's
the grand plan.
Okay. And you're like, "Okay, wait a
minute here.
Why would China agree
to such a stupid deal?" Well, there are
actually lots of reasons, okay? The
first major reason is Taiwan.
Okay.
So, again,
the United States doesn't really need
Taiwan. Taiwan is over here.
And what Taiwan does, that's very
important for you for you United States
strategically, is it blocks
China from the Pacific. Okay? It's
something called the first island chain.
It's part of the first island chain. It
That's in the blue.
So, that's why Chinese American
policymakers think Taiwan is important.
But you think about it, okay? If you're
American, you're like,
"Wait a minute here, okay? Let Let us
say I lose Taiwan. Let's say I I to
China,
'I want Taiwan to return to motherland."
Okay, what happens now?
Well,
now you create a problem because
Taiwan now can block
this area.
Okay? It can separate Southeast Asia
into two parts. South Korea and Japan on
one part, the Philippines, Southeast
Asia, Singapore another part. Okay, do
you guys see this map?
You now divide Southeast Asia into two.
This is important. Why? Because
guess what? Japan, South Korea gets most
of their energy through the Strait of
Malacca. You basically block off South
Korea and Japan from a lot of the global
economy.
In which case, there's actually no way
in hell South Korea and Japan agree to
let Taiwan return to China. Doesn't make
sense.
So, by saying By the United States
saying, "Hey, I want China and Taiwan to
marry again."
what you've done is
you've now transferred the power from
from you, the United States, to South
Korea and Japan.
You understand that?
That's why strategically it makes
perfect sense for Trump to say,
"Taiwan belongs to China."
Okay?
Okay? So, Taiwan issue problem is
solved.
Now,
there's another There's There's another
issue in that China, as we discussed, is
very dependent on energy and food from
South America. Okay? So, you can see
this is South America.
And you can see all these projects in
the yellow
that China is building. Okay? So, the
pink is something that's already built
or under construction. The yellow are
planned. It's These are huge projects.
Okay? So, what America has done is
basically taken over Venezuela.
Hey.
And Trump
announced this like I think 2 days ago.
We're going to make Venezuela
the 51st state.
What What What would Why would you want
to do that? Because now he blocks China
from South America. And if you look at
this map, this tells you energy energy
supply, okay? So, if you So, this is war
in the Middle East, which means that the
Middle East you can forget about. So,
China now can get energy from Russia or
the Western Hemisphere.
China doesn't want to depend entirely on
Russia. China will buy more Russian oil,
but it does not want to become entirely
dependent on Russia. Also, Russia cannot
actually meet all of China's energy
needs, okay? So, now China is forced to
negotiate with the United States to have
access to the to to the Western
Hemisphere.
Does China care? The answer is no.
China only cares about stability and
price.
Stability and cost.
I want it things at a fair price
and I want this to be a stable and
predictable relationship.
If I'm China, I I I would prefer if
America controlled the entire Western
Hemisphere because now I can I can I can
just negotiate with one government as
opposed to like all these other
governments, many of whom are corrupt.
Does that make sense, guys?
So, would China agree to this?
Absolutely.
China has actually no problem with
America controlling the Western
Hemisphere if it means stability and
cost are controlled.
Okay?
Does Does that make sense to you guys?
Okay. Um yeah.
But, does China hold's attitude like
about
America controlling Venezuela because
like using morals like they said they
conquered
>> No. No. No. No. No. No. But, why would
they do this? China would
>> care.
I don't Don't Guys, don't talk about
sovereignty, rights, morality in this
class, okay? It's all game theory.
I don't care what this thinks.
Game theory is people are going to
behave in their best interest. It's that
simple.
Okay? No morality, no human rights, no
sovereignty.
All right? Okay. So, China doesn't care
who controls Venezuela as long it's a
stable place where China can get cheap
oil.
It doesn't make sense.
Okay. All right. The last thing is
AI.
Okay?
All right. So, as you can see, the
United States is the world's leader in
the in I simply because it has the most
data centers. In fact, America plans to
build more and more data centers.
China is trying to compete, but its data
center development is constrained by the
fact that it has limited access to
semiconductors,
to chips.
And so,
China wants more chips from the United
States.
And the United States can say yes.
But you're like, "No, no, no, wait,
wait, wait, no, no, no. Doesn't that
mean that
China could one day overtake the United
States?"
Could China just reverse engineer and
steal the IP from the semiconductors?
No. That's not how semi- semiconductors
work. Semiconductors are so
sophisticated that it's an entire global
supply chain, okay? These semiconductors
are designed in California,
then they are sent to Taiwan to be
manufactured,
then they're sent on to the Philippines
to be
value added, then sent to sent to China
to be added to components, then it's
sold to Europe.
And all the while, you have to extract
resources from Africa, from South
America in order to
feed these semiconductors. Do you
understand? So, in other words, there's
actually no way that one nation, only
one nation, can control the entire
supply chain.
So, as long as America can control the
trade network, America will always have
the advantage in semiconductors.
Okay? There's actually no way China can
reverse the production of the
semiconductors because it's too
sophisticated. It's too expensive.
Only
Only one country can specialize only one
field.
Okay?
Doesn't make sense.
Okay.
So, that's why this guy is important.
Okay? Jensen Huang of Nvidia.
Before
he was not supposed to come to China.
Okay? It was announced he was not coming
to China.
Then, as Trump was flying through Alaska
to refuel, he got on board in Alaska. It
was a last-minute addition. But, not
only that, but there were two business
people that were with Trump on his
plane. Elon Musk and Jensen Huang.
Okay? So, what happened? So, I work in
business negotiation. I'll tell you
exactly what happened. What happened was
that
Scott Bessent and Holly Fang they were
negotiating this grand bargain. Just the
contours of this grand bargain in South
Korea. China wants, first and foremost,
Nvidia chips.
Scott Bessent wants, first and foremost,
access to the Chinese financial market.
Okay? There was a There was impasse. So,
Trump just basically said, "I'm not I'm
not going to bring this guy." Okay? And
then, as Trump was going to come to
China,
there was a breakthrough.
And Trump's like, "Okay, as a sign of
goodwill, I will now wing him."
Okay? That this is how business
negotiations work. This is confusing for
people because usually we don't want
business people to run pure politics, to
run diplomacy because they are
unpredictable, okay?
But this is how business negotiations
work.
All right.
So,
this is just the
uh basic framework for how the US grand
bargain will turn out, in my opinion.
Okay? So, to summarize, what China wants
is access to cheap energy of the Western
Hemisphere. It wants Nvidia chips to
fuel its AI. Um
um and
it wants
access to the US market, okay? Those
Those are three things that China wants.
America wants access to Chinese
financial markets. Basically, it wants
Chinese consumers to buy stable coins in
order to finance
the US debt.
It wants to better control China's AI
development. Why? Because
it with AI, China and America are not
competitive, they're partners. Because I
as I told you last class, the entire
entire point of AI is to create a
surveillance state. Okay? Now, America
has technology, but China has a lot of
people and there's no privacy here. So,
in other words, what what America can do
is use China as a lab in order to test
out surveillance technology that it it
could not test out in America.
Okay? So, America wants access to
China's
uh AI market. And the third thing that
um America wants is Chinese
manufacturing.
Why? Because Chinese manufacturing is
the best in the world. So, not only does
America want China to continue
manufacturing
in order to buy US dollars, but also
wants to import manufacturing Chinese
manufacturing into America
and to Venezuela as well, right? Because
a Venezuela has all these
resources that can be extracted and
turned into manufactured goods.
Americans don't want to do it because
it's too expensive, it's too hard work,
but the Chinese will do this.
Okay? So, this is what the grand bargain
will look like.
Any questions?
Okay. So, these are predictions. This is
the way I see I see the situation and
we'll know in a couple couple days if
I'm right or wrong. Okay? So, we'll talk
next week.